[Musique]
ils expriment leurs colères et ils vont
voter un coup à l'extrême droite parfois
aussi à gauche mais bien souvent ils
votent plus et donc il faut d'abord
aller leur convaincre exactement
on en a marre des donneurs de leçons
sachez-le vous êtes une donnée de leçon
mais ils n'existe plutôt tous les dans
tous les partis non il y a pas des
nations mais non il y a pas des nations
dans la liberté d'expression on a arrêté
respecter un peu les Français
arrêtez laissez parler vous fatiguez
tout le monde vous êtes insupportable je
me tais alors vous êtes insupportable
Géraldine arrêtez de dire aux Français
il faut faire ça arrêtez de dire en
français il faut faire si les Français
ils font ce qu'ils veulent les moutons
j'en peux plus voilà donc chacun fait ce
que vous êtes un montant mais pas du
tout
complètement
choisir tout seul et je vous le dis
c'est des personnes comme vous qui vont
nous mener à peut-être et lire des
extrêmes parce que c'est extrêmement
dangereux que vous faites il essaie
plutôt les Français faire ce qu'ils
veulent et ils feront toujours très bien
voilà donc c'était hier donc c'est vrai
que il y a eu plein de reprises il y a
plein de journalistes qui nous ont
appelé est-ce que Géraldine maillet va
revenir dans l'émission est-ce que
j'irai ma vie va quitter la France voilà
non mais c'est vrai qu'il y a eu ça fait
un boss incroyable sachez juste une
chose c'est qu'ici on se dit tout dans
touche pas mon pote et ça vous prouve
bien en tout cas que rien n'est préparé
je sais pas du tout ce que vont dire les
chroniqueurs Géraldine maillet ne sait
pas du tout ce que je vais dire c'est je
sais pas du tout ce qu'elle va dire et
vraiment ça c'est pour ça que les
missions marchent on est comme ça après
c'est vrai que j'ai dit à Géraldine
voilà ce que je pensais après voilà on
se les dit plein de fois on s'accrochait
des nombreuses fois tous les deux avec
Gilles Verdez hier aussi ça a été il a
craché ça m'empêche pas de voilà de
d'héberger Fatou
voilà donc je vais vous dire avant tout
il faut savoir c'est que tu es pas P
c'est une famille voilà alors après
voilà il y en a qui parte il y en a qui
reviennent mais c'est vrai que voilà on
peut s'engueuler on peut on peut se dire
des choses mais après voilà on sait
parfois violent à l'antenne mais c'est
vrai qu'on c'est voilà TPMP c'est la vie
c'est en direct il y a pas de montage et
c'est vrai qu'il n'y a pas de de faux
sanglants et on se dit tout et je l'ai
dit voilà il y a trois jours je disais
que Géraldine était la meilleure
chroniqueuse de TPMP ça m'empêche pas
d'être pas d'accord avec elle sur plein
de choses et c'est vrai que aujourd'hui
voilà j'ai hier j'étais pas d'accord
avec elle et il y a ce dont motion sur
lesquelles je suis pas d'accord avec
elle elle l'océan n'est-ce pas Géraldine
non c'est vrai
bah moi quand même j'ai trouvé que
c'était très pénible hier oui ça très
désagréable très vieux c'est pénible
pour moi aussi très agressif
quand vous me dites quand vous me dites
vous vous aimez les nazions c'est aussi
très pénible dans des choses comme ça
surtout voilà c'est n'importe quoi donc
on peut pas dire ça non plus à l'antenne
c'est vrai que c'est pénible pour tous
les deux donc du coup ben moi je suis
encore une fois pas du tout une victime
pas du tout une diva je suis juste une
chroniqueuse je suis là pour me donner
mon avis effectivement quand vous dites
donneuse de leçon bah en fait quand on
donne son avis forcément on donne on
donne une leçon non ben si non on peut
donner son avis sans dire aux autres ce
qui doit faire et ce qui doit pas faire
aux autres ce qu'il veut vous allez
faire je donne je donne mon avis encore
une fois moi je vous ai trouvé très très
agressif j'ai trouvé que c'était proche
franchement je vous le dis parce que
vous dites la famille et tout
franchement hier j'ai pas du tout senti
la famille de votre bébé
harcèlement vraiment même presque moral
un peu d'acharnement ça m'a fait du mal
oui mais je vous dis mais vous aussi
vous savez quand vous quand vous me
quand vous me dites oui nazion est-ce
que ça alors pour moi pour moi ça pour
moi si si vous me dites alors vous aimez
les nazis pour moi je vous dis c'est une
énorme insulte voilà donc vous m'avez
insulté donc on refait le film on va
retourner la séquence puisque je disais
juste qu'il y avait des gros puscule
d'extrême droite chez les trois
Villepinte vous êtes donneuse de leçon
mais Siri je vous explique toute ma vie
je vais vous dire un truc c'est pas on
n'est pas c'est un ensemble c'est un
ensemble de votre carrière voilà mais là
c'est pas pour ça c'est un ensemble de
Raymond voulait dire un truc hier non
non moi j'ai pensé vraiment si tu
permets et ensuite j'ai aussi pas
apprécié quelque chose et je préfère
vous le dire parce que je trouve que
c'est très bien je vous remercie
d'ailleurs de me donner cette liberté de
pouvoir m'exprimer
[ __ ] aussi dans votre vocabulaire en
gros tu sors ça veut dire que je suis
pas d'accord avec vous et je pense que
c'est la force de l'émission
pas d'accord avec moi ici j'ai le
dernier je suis jamais d'accord avec lui
jamais d'accord avec moi Matthieu
Delormeau
avec Bernard Moutier vous savez très
bien que c'est une vanne entre Bernard
Montiel et qu'on fait avec tout le monde
voilà ce que j'ai vraiment pas aimé j'ai
trouvé que c'était un peu la la ligne un
peu rouge c'est le côté je sais combien
vous gagnez euh
genre en gros je suis votre patron vous
êtes vous êtes je sais combien vous
gagnez donc vous pouvez pas vous
permettre d'avoir de ce genre de
positionnement c'est pas du tout c'est
parce que vous donnez je vais vous dire
que ça veut dire qu'on en fait le patron
donc je la fermer ma gueule alors vous
n'avez rien compris
vous croyez plus intelligente
vous êtes multimillionnaire
laissez-moi parler c'est ça votre
problème vous ne laissez pas parler les
gens c'est votre technique on le sait à
chaque fois c'est le problème bah nous
si on a été blessé
ça fait des semaines qu'on est baissé
ce que je vous disais c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les Français et on peut
pas leur dire pour qui voter pourquoi
faire pour qui aimer ne pas aimer
aujourd'hui à des Français qui sont
énormes souffrances qui gagne
le 10 du mois ils savent pas ce qu'ils
vont faire ils savent pas comment ils
vont boucler la fin de mois donc vous ce
que je vous disais sur votre salaire ça
n'a rien à voir avec votre patron c'est
que voilà je sais que je le dis pour
tout le monde ici ici on est bien on est
au chaud on est tranquille on peut pas
donner de leçons aux autres on peut pas
dire aux autres il faut pas voter pour
un tel faut pas voter pour un tel qu'il
fallait pas voter pour un thème c'est ce
que vous dites depuis des semaines un
peu voilà vous essayez voilà je vous dis
laissez les Français
savent ils peuvent on peut pas juger à
la place des Français chacun a sa vie
mais chacun vit sa vie comme il entend
et chacun a ses problèmes on peut pas se
mettre à la place des Français et à la
place des problèmes des Français vous on
a toujours l'impression vous mettez à la
place des problèmes de français les
Français je vous dis il y en a beaucoup
qui souffrent et qui se disent mais moi
non mais aujourd'hui
je sais
pas une phrase politique je vous dis
juste que vous êtes un peu d'honneur de
leçon sur ça et j'ai le droit de vous le
dire voilà maintenant c'est donner son
avis pas du tout pas donné son avis on
peut donner son avis mais vous orienter
à chaque fois voilà c'est un petit peu
qu'est-ce que tu voulais dire non moi
j'ai trouvé que d'abord ce que j'aime
ici moi c'est qui se passe des choses
c'est une émission en direct c'est ce
qui fait la force de TPMP un jour il y
en a un qui se barre un jour il y en a
un qui est là un jour ça s'engueule il y
a pas d'autres émissions où tu peux
aller au frontal comme ça avec ton
patron dans la vraie vie tu vas pouvoir
tu parles pas avec ton patron comme ça
dans la vraie vie et le lendemain tu
reviens pas un patron ils vont sortir
des vannes vous avez 19 Bentley vous
êtes des bateaux des machins tu ne dis
pas ça un patron moi ce que j'aime ici
c'est cette liberté qu'on a et hier je
vais vous dire comment j'ai pris la
séquence parce que c'est en direct au
début j'ai dit comme tout le temps il y
a une espèce de de jeu entre Géraldine
et Cyril qui font que elle a parlé du
meeting de de Zemmour à Villepinte même
pas le mythique
c'était l'ensemble du truc moi je me
suis dit quand je te vois démarrer au
quart de tour et on revoit l'extrait tu
démarres au quart de tour j'ai
l'impression que n'importe aurait pu
prendre Mathieu aurait pu prendre la
même chose Benjamin aurait pu prendre la
même chose Valérie Benaim aura pu
prendre la même chose et Géraldine a
pris parce que Géraldine elle va au
combat avec toi et c'est elle qui a pris
hier c'est ça qui est dans le fond ce
que tu disais c'était arrêtons de donner
des leçons aux gens qui eux souffrent
qui eux ont du mal à boucler leur
financement qui eux ne croient plus en
la politique ni de gauche ni du milieu
ni de droite ils en ont ras-le-bol et ce
que tu as dit hier soir c'était plus ça
j'ai l'impression que on aurait pu tous
prendre même moi j'aurais pu le prendre
ça hier et c'est tombé sur Géraldine
c'est chiant parce que à chaque fois
vous êtes en train de vous vous
injectiver le monsieur c'est pas c'est
pour vanner à chaque fois il dit de
monter le [ __ ] aussi moi je veux que
cette émission elle reste comme ça je
veux que j'ai raté là parce qu'elle a à
sa place entièrement dans l'émission
elle sert elle a elle a le courage
d'être contre toi d'être contre tout le
monde et la force de cette émission
c'est en direct si les gens veulent
regarder des émissions pipoter ou ça on
l'aura coupé et on leur a vendu le monde
de Oui-Oui allez-y regardez des
émissions enregistrées mais moi j'adore
cette émission c'est pour ça que j'aime
bien vous sentir de temps en temps
rentrer sortir bravo bravo
non mais c'est vrai que une fois c'est
vrai que là je trouve faim franchement
que Géraldine vous allez très loin sur
vos mots harcèlement vous savez ce que
c'est le harcèlement vous savez ce que
c'est le harcèlement Géraldine maillet
pour parler de harcèlement moi je me
sens harcelé par vous aussi je vous le
dis parce que quand vous me suivez quand
vous me coupez la parole à chaque fois
moi aussi je peux dire que c'est du
harcèlement vous savez ce que c'est que
le harcèlement
Géraldine parce que c'est pareil
Géraldine maillet vous êtes les copines
est-ce que vous savez ce que c'est que
les personnes qui sont victimes de
harcèlement c'est très grave ce que vous
voulez dire parce que vous là en faisant
ça les vraies personnes qui sont
harcelées elles se disent quoi Géraldine
maillet elle a harcelé parce que Cyril
Hanouna lui a coupé la parole et qu'il a
remis dans sa place ou qu'ils ont une
discussion toutes les tous les deux
c'est très grave faites attention faites
attention à ce que vous dites faites
attention à ce que vous dites parce
qu'il y a vraiment des gens qui sont
vraiment harcelés donc hier vous êtes
frontières cela l'antenne je me suis
senti oui j'ai trouvé que c'était très
particulier
donc là vous avez choisi le mauvais mot
mais vous allez peut-être trouver un
autre mot oui j'ai le vernaise bon moi
je vais vous dire c'est l'ADN de
l'émission bah oui même de s'engueuler
là de s'engueuler hier seulement c'est
compliqué autre chose donc ce qui s'est
passé pour moi ça reste dans l'ADN de
l'émission
mais c'est ça le jeu c'est que on a des
yeux on a on a on a des sensibilités
différentes on a des avis différents
c'est ça qui fait la force de l'émission
si vous n'acceptez pas qu'on en parle et
ben on en parle pas voilà vous voyez
vous coupez Gilles Verdez encore laissé
parler les gens bah moi c'est ce que je
l'ai coupé non donc j'en ai discuté avec
vous hier et jamais redis les mots que
je vous ai dit pour moi tout ça c'était
viril mais correct comme dans un match
de foot un combat acharné un match de
box mais oui j'ai rallye ça vous fait
sourire mais c'était c'est ce que j'ai
ressenti si si bien sûr c'est
inadmissible de dire harcèlement
je trouve que Géraldine alors que vous
pouvez dire ce que vous avez préparé
vous pouvez parler là je trouve que ce
n'est pas du tout ce que j'avais de la
liberté qu'on vous laisse dans
l'émission c'est-à-dire que pas je
prends mon exemple j'ai une liberté
totale je suis en antagonisme quasi
permanent avec vous d'ailleurs avec moi
aussi avec Cyril encore plus souvent et
je l'adore aussi donc on a une liberté
totale et la rançon de la liberté c'est
que face à nous on a un animateur qui
dit ce qui pense c'est-à-dire que lui
aussi on va avoir un débat frontal et il
ne faut pas oublier moi c'est ce que je
retiens c'est que les gens qui regardent
touchent pas à mon pas pourquoi vous
cherchez la tête Matthieu laissez-moi
finir les gens qui regardent touchent
pas à mon poste il représente le spectre
total de l'élection on a des gens et
c'est la force qui vont d'un extrême à
l'autre tout le monde nous regarde et
donc c'est plutôt de donner des clés à
ces gens-là de les éclairer de leur
parler pour que se fasse leur opinion
moi c'est comme ça que je ressens
l'émission est très franchement jamais
je n'ai eu la moindre censure donc
Delphine après voilà Géraldine tu
dégages une image de femme très fort tu
t'exprime très bien tu tiens toujours
tête à Cyril donc c'est ça le jeu en
plus
de tenir tête à toi maintenant ce qu'il
faut aussi comprendre Cyril c'est que
malgré l'enveloppe de femmes fortes et
ta beauté froide et vraiment de femme
forte bah il y a une sensibilité
peut-être plus importante
elle a été blessée elle le dit donc je
pense surtout à moi
harcèlement mais bien sûr
le vrai problème c'est que dans
l'émission et je vais parler pour moi il
faut il faut accepter que c'est une
mission de télé bien sûr qu'il se passe
des choses moi Cyril me met en boîte ça
fait des mois donc je parle pas etc
honnêtement j'ai 30 ans de carrière je
pourrais être très mal le prendre et
parfois c'est vrai que c'est un peu dur
l'autre fois Gilles il m'a un peu blessé
j'ai envoyé un texto mais je pense que
quand on est dans sur ce plateau une
fois et c'est valable pour gérer qu'en
plus à un courage énorme parce qu'elle
dit vraiment ce qu'elle pense après ça
reste une mission de télé donc les
échanges qui se passent sur un plateau
même si parfois ils sont ils ont virés
ils sont difficiles même si tu peux être
peut-être choqué parce que Cyril ça peut
pas devenir une histoire parce que si
c'est une histoire c'est que il y a pas
d'émission parce que toi tu es une
machine de télé
on n'est pas la peau arrêtons de nouveau
la face on est ici bien sûr
on sait très bien pourquoi on est là
quel est votre rôle le personnel etc
mais je comprends qu'elle était qu'elle
est mal vécu la séquence en revanche je
trouve que quand on sort de ce plateau
on doit se dire c'était de la télévision
même si on met son orgueil de côté même
si on a été blessé une liberté totale
moi je me suis pris la tête avec Myriam
elle est partie
on sait pas voilà c'était fini ce qu'il
y a sur ce plateau est-ce que les gens
disent est-ce que les journalistes
doivent comprendre plutôt que faire des
cancers la putaclic dès qu'il y a un
problème d'ailleurs quand il y a un peu
d'émotion sur le plateau il en parle
jamais d'ailleurs bien sûr exactement
ça mais est-ce qu'on vous a déjà dit de
dire quelque chose ou de ne pas dire
quelque chose ici je sais même pas ce
que vous allez dire demande de ne rien
dire
je fais très bien mais non mais jamais
il faut le dire ça
il y a même pas c'est on est même pas au
niveau de l'Ascension c'est même pas une
impulsion une indication une une
incitation jamais personne ne sait ce
qu'on va dire moi j'ai écrit mes trucs
là personne les a lu personne sait ce
que je vais dire donc c'est la liberté
on comprend pas ce que non mais on a une
liberté totale et je trouve que cette
séquence le montre bien c'est un échange
très musclé vous avez été très casse
Géraldine a été très cash ça l'a touché
ça vous a touché Géraldine elle a le
courage de dire ce qu'elle pense et
c'est très bien et moi ce que j'ai
apprécié quelque part là là c'est des
mots ah non mais je pense je pense que
je pense qu'en fait elle mesure enfin je
pense mais je pense que là dans le
contexte actuel de dire harcèlement
c'est très lourd et c'est ça tu as voulu
dire que ça a touché mais je pense
qu'elle ne le pense pas ce qu'elle a dit
en tout cas moi quelque part bizarrement
même si cette séquence était musclée
j'ai bien aimé quelque part parce qu'il
y a plusieurs on arrête pas de dire dans
cette émission pour t'aider c'est
hypocrite qu'on ment au téléspectateurs
qu'on cache tout là dans l'émission on
le joue et je préfère ça que des gens
qui se font des grands souris à
l'antenne et qui s'engueulent en
coulisses et là on montre la vérité aux
gens quelque part c'est une bonne
séquence et voilà je pense que vous avez
été tous les deux très touchés par cette
séquence et que vous respectez beaucoup
dans le fond Géraldine elle le sait oui
vous respectez rien comme ça voilà
maintenant c'est vrai que voilà depuis
la radio avec toi elle a tout fait avec
moi tous les projets oui Beatrice
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
moi je sais que
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Béatrice Béatrice je ne peux ne pas
l’interroger
justement la juste avant cette séquence
on a une nous un petit voilà moi ce que
vous m'avez dit la veille aussi ça
m'avait je me suis sentie humiliée
touché parce que je suis nouvelle ici et
en fait vous m'aviez fait comprendre que
parce que je n'avais pas vos opinions
vous aviez du mal avec moi en fait c'est
ce que vous avez dit plus méchamment en
gros et donc en fait aujourd'hui vous
êtes en train de vous comprenez c'est un
peu paradoxalement
oui mais vous êtes vous avez plus de
pouvoir que moi sur les sur l'émission
parce que vous connaissez très bien tout
le monde vous êtes là depuis très
longtemps je suis en position
d'infériorité par rapport à vous et je
trouve que c'était pas correct dans la
façon de le dire maintenant je voulais
dire c'est fini on passe à autre chose
je suis pas rancunière il y a pas de
problème maintenant je voudrais juste
rajouter que effectivement donner son
avis ce n'est pas donné des leçons on
peut donner son avis et c'est vrai que
pendant des mois et des mois
voilà vous avez soutenu je suis désolé
de revenir à ça mais des mesures qui ont
été extrêmement dures si la population
qui donne la leçon inverse et c'est la
finir mais c'est vrai qu'elle a le droit
de le dire
et je voulais juste dire voilà
maintenant je elle a été très dure avec
certaines personnes et parfois certains
invités et et
son rôle c'est son rôle de donner son
avis mais parfois c'était donner des
leçons et être très agressive avec des
gens qui jouaient leur vie qui jouaient
leur vie et voilà
vous n'êtes pas choqué par le mot
harcèlement c'est ça qui est
non mais ça c'est une admission j'adore
Géraldine le morcellement on l'enlève je
pense que Géraldine l'enlève on l'oublie
non mais c'est très rare on l'oublie de
la soirée
c'est très on a senti que ça vous
touchait
une telle liberté ici on sait honteux de
dire ça excusez-moi
j'avais une liberté incroyable je vous
parle même pas avant oui oublie ce mot
ça pollue le débat ah oui pas le
débattre ce soir moi le débat ce soir de
deux choses la première d'abord c'est
que je note le le la sensibilité je note
que ça l'a beaucoup affecté je le vois
dans ses yeux aussi je note qu'elle a
été très affectée très triste donc en
tant que tous ici on doit se dire voilà
donc il y a une petite maladresse je
sais aussi Cyril et je l'ai vécu aussi
que vous pouvez être parfois brutal mais
je le sais aussi on s'est déjà dit
parfois des horreurs et 10 minutes après
c'est fini on est comme ça on est comme
ça on est une émission un peu à la Polac
ou ça passe tous les sens et c'est fini
maintenant il ne faut pas nier la peine
qu'elle a eu voilà bien sûr
et moi j'ai bien aimé hier ce que j'ai
bien aimé hier c'est que pardon c'est
génial
qui le fait à la tenue tête à Cyril
Cyril évidemment c'est défendu et il le
fait très bien et parfois il le fait
mieux que nous parce qu'il est plus
puissant donc quand il commence à lancer
la machine bah c'est moi c'est notre
batteuse ça c'est sûr maintenant la
vérité de tout ça c'est que voilà c'est
qu'effectivement c'est c'est l'ADN de
l'émission c'est comme ça que ça se
passe et je sais je sais je sais bien
sûr que Cyril hier soir tu étais aussi
emmerdé qu'elle je sais quand tu es chez
elle parce que
de cette séquence là hein
j'aime pas quoi c'est ça les deux parce
que quand il parle
bien sûr
recommence reconnaissant quand même que
heureusement qu'on a Géraldine elle y va
je l'ai dit lundi chroniqueuse de la
dernière mais moi j'ai bien aimé ce qui
c'est que je sais très bien qu'en
rentrant bien sûr tu avais de la peine
et tu avais de la peine je l'aime
beaucoup ça méritait de vous étiez
emmerder tous les deux je vous connais
par cœur c'est ça un match retire le
terme j'ai pas aimé le terme brutal que
tu dis parce que nous aussi quand on se
parle c'est casse c'est franc il y a pas
de brutalité il y a un dialogue
complètement sans fil
on se dit la vérité l'autre jour l'autre
jour Benjamin t'envoyer un texto il
avait été un petit peu vexé par ce que
tu avais dit tout ça on est en direct
parfois on est maladroit on est brutaux
mais on a cru qu'un jour il a cru le
couper la gueule on en a rien fait
et maintenant on s'adore tu vois ce que
je veux dire mais évidemment c'est du
direct on sort les trucs on se coupe la
parole
et les mots importants
il est parti en claquant la porte
l'année dernière je me barre j'arrête
c'est fini et il est là aujourd'hui mais
attention
elle est resté hier qui se battent dans
une autre boîte elle reste dans une
autre boîte dans la vraie vie tu as une
convocation tout de suite sur le champ
ils sont pas fait ils sont pas convoqués
ils sont passés
il a raison il a raison on fait ça tu
vas dans le bureau tout de suite après
l'émission
de Cyril un jour je publierai peut-être
ses SMS qu'on a ensemble c'est que tu
peux avoir tu m'as fait chier hier et et
et 10 minutes avant un cœur je t'aime
mon bébé
c'est ça c'est vraiment là ce que les
gens qu'on faut qu'il comprenne on
dirait les mecs encore une fois mais ne
n'y pas sa peine
j'ai jamais gagné sa peine c'est pas je
peux comprendre qu'elle ait été choquée
et et blessé mais est-ce que puisque les
gens se font comprendre que là pareil on
règle les comptes devant les
téléspectateurs on offre au
téléspectateurs un truc en direct que
normalement dans une autre société c'est
en tête d'accord et tu envoies
recommandé et je veux pouvoir ta sale
gueule c'est comme ça que ça se passe
dans les autres non parce que
j'arrive
quand je vous dis que la télé vous êtes
dans un monde bizarre c'est un monde
bizarre c'est surtout vrai ce qui est
étonnant et je le jure sur ma mère il
n'y a pas une personne autour de cette
table pour qui j'ai une inimitié il y en
a que je vois plus c'est que j'adore
une personne que je n'aime pas je
m'engueule avec vous non c'est pas vrai
non non c'est pas vrai il n'y a pas une
personne que je n'aime pas il y a des
gens que j'adore et que je vais en
dehors bien sûr il y a pas des limitée
et c'est ça que c'est ça qui est bien
aussi
c'est vrai que c'est c'est un contexte
moi qui suis un peu extérieur à tout ça
dans Géraldine je trouve que c'est un
peu l'arroseur arrosé je trouve que
effectivement le mot harcèlement c'est
un peu un peu dur et un peu excessif
mais c'est vrai que ça c'est pas vous
fonctionnez pas comme dans une
entreprise normale il y a beaucoup
d'émotion il y a beaucoup d'après et
vous êtes là aussi pour faire des images
donc voilà enfin je peux comprendre
qu'elle ait été bless mais elle aussi
peut être très dure et dans ces cas-là
elle vous dit bah c'est que de la télé
donc à un moment donné on peut pas faire
faire ce qu'on reprochait ce qu'on fait
et puis il peut y avoir qu'un patron ici
ou deux parce qu'on est deux animateurs
c'est après on peut non mais c'est vrai
on tourne
tout ce qui a été dit moi j'ai trouvé
que c'était formidable j'ai écouté mes
camarades avec beaucoup de tendresse et
d'intérêt donc je les remercie beaucoup
pour leur mot mais voilà moi j'ai
d'abord je vous remercie de m'avoir
laissé parler de d'avoir écouté d'avoir
senti la séquence d'hier parce que je
l'ai dit avec toute ma franchise et mon
honnêteté comme à chaque fois je prends
la parole sur ce plateau
voilà et donc moi pour moi tout va bien
j'ai un câlin un
[Applaudissements]
câliner le tour de table non j'ai très
mal pris ça c'est vraiment
surtout de ma part avec toute la liberté
que je vous laisse et inadmissible parce
ça va faire les choux gras
une sorte d'acharnement c'est vrai hier
quand vous vous me laissez pas parler
bah oui mais sauf que Cyril vous êtes
mon patron
vous savez ce que vous venez de dire je
suis votre patron mais vous voyez qu'on
parle des galets Galiens on a parlé tous
les deux et là c'est on a un débat tous
les deux ça acharnement
on a eu un débat tous les deux monsieur
je ne sais pas qui vous donne
est-ce que tu veux la vie d'un
téléspectateur tu as raison c'est
important moi j'ai trouvé que tu échange
était hyper violent j'ai rarement vu ça
ici bah oui et la seule chose que je
regrette en tant que téléspectateur
c'est que je n'ai pas compris la vie de
Géraldine c'est-à-dire que c'était
tellement une embrouille entre les deux
que on a
voulu tout à l'heure il est parti au
quart de tour parce que si c'était
n'importe qui leur a mangé la même la
même douille je pense que Benjamin
aurait mangé pareil Montiel aurait mangé
pareil
je te dis ce qu'il a dit quand il y a
pas compris l'échange de jardin parce
que tu es parti au quart de tour et si
vous regardez bien des extraits je pense
que c'est pas vraiment c'est Géraldine
tu as mangé il faut savoir que même les
téléspectateurs ils nous considèrent
comme leur famille ils se sont de
famille c'est notre famille
ils aiment bien qu'on se parle voilà
mais ils aiment bien c'est vrai que ça
leur fait de la peine aussi de voir de
chroniqueurs qui s'entendent pas
l'animateur avec une personne un des
chroniqueurs avec qui il y a eu un
accrochage mais je vous le dis c'est
nous comme l'a dit Mathieu Mathieu et
moi on s'accrochait 50 fois 2 minutes
après on est en train de se bouffer
on s'enlève les micro je reviens plus
jamais et tu reviens et c'est fini et
c'est vrai
comme une famille c'est comme une
famille ce qu'il faut expliquer aussi au
téléspectateurs on parlait des
téléréalité tout à l'heure nous aussi on
vit en communauté plus de temps ensemble
qu'avec nos bras on se voit 5 6 heures
par jour on est tous les deux
donc parfois on en a marre parfois on
peut plus blairer parfois le ton monte
et c'est normal ça fait aussi partie de
l'émission C'est vrai que la séquence
quand on la prend quand on l'isole elle
peut paraître violente mais dans le
cadre d'une vie en communauté toute
l'année c'est normal que vous preniez la
tête une fois dans l'année il y a rien
de choqué hier on a une discussion c'est
vous savez ce que disent des gens
harcèlement et acharnement c'est pas bon
il y a des mots qu'on doit pas dire et
surtout à un patron comme toi c'est ce
que disent aussi les téléspectateurs on
peut pas dire ça je vous le dis
acharnement harcèlement Gilles
vraiment franchement c'est pas possible
dans les yeux mais on peut pas regarder
pas et je vous aime vraiment je vous le
dis Géraldine je trouve que c'est pas du
tout un mot approprié
on est on est dans une discussion
il y a de sa part en plus et c'est très
grave ça veut dire ce qu'on veut
acharnement
j'ai jamais eu autant de liberté depuis
ça fait longtemps que je bosse ici
c'est une ambiance mais je vous dis à
maman harcèlement c'est c'est vraiment
ça ça c'est joli c'est pas acceptable je
vous dis ça n'est pas acceptable Myriam
qui est qui est non c'est pas vrai
vous regrettez pas de non mais après je
regrette oui peut-être que le mot le mot
et Géraldine qu'est-ce qu'elle veut je
ne la force pas à dire qu'elle regrette
quoi que ce soit voilà elle elle dit si
elle le regrette pas
d'accord avec moi j'ai toujours dit ce
que je pensais tout le temps pour toi
ça a été vous trouvez pas que c'est un
petit peu quand même exagéré comme comme
mot alors peut-être que
à la hauteur
jusque là tout va bien
non mais Géraldine
accumulation et j'ai trouvé que c'était
effectivement compliqué mais encore une
fois je vous ai dit je suis pas une
victime je suis pas une diva je suis pas
une petite femme fragile je peux me
défendre j'ai pris la parole je me suis
défendue je vous ai expliqué point voilà
moi je suis tout va bien
et vous le savez ici moi
j'essaie vraiment d'être c'est aussi il
faut gérer toute une équipe il faut
gérer toutes les équipes j'essaie d'être
le plus juste possible parfois forcément
on est on prend parfois les mauvaises
décisions ça fait 12 ans que je fais
l'émission maintenant on va fêter
l'anniversaire demain c'est normal
parfois que je prenne les mauvaises
décisions que voilà que je puisse faire
des j'ai des mauvaises réactions mais
j'essaie
en moyenne d'être le plus vraiment le
plus juste possible avec tout le monde
il y a bien sûr des antagonistes entre
les chroniqueurs voilà il y a des
parfois des problèmes mais j'essaie vous
essayez de que vous ne le sentiez pas du
tout d'ailleurs vous vous sentez pas du
tout les problèmes qui peut y avoir dans
l'équipe etc j'essaie de le faire voilà
le mieux possible depuis 12 ans
maintenant c'est vrai que je vous l'ai
dit je vous le dis parce que j'essaie
d'être le mieux possible avec vous
en temps les mots et je le redis
harcèlement et acharnement avec ce que
je fais ce que j'essaie de faire pour
vous et ce que j'essaie vraiment de vous
amener comme confort de vie depuis
maintenant 12 ans et d'essayer de vous
laisser le maximum de liberté je trouve
que c'est inacceptable voilà je vous le
dis maintenant Géraldine a dit ce
qu'elle pense elle dit ce qu'elle veut
mais je trouve que c'est compliqué oui
non je pense qu'elle a juste voulu dire
que vous étiez dur avec elle et que
c'est vrai que le mot harcèlement il a
quand même changé de signification avec
tout ce qui se passe aujourd'hui avec
meetou ça a changé les relations au
travail aujourd'hui mais c'est perçu
comme ça aujourd'hui vous avez des
patrons qui harcèlent vraiment leurs
salariés qui est harcèle sexuellement
qu'il les menace
il s'agissait absolument pas de
judiciarisme le mot en fait c'était pas
oui mais c'est ce qui va se passer
en lui-même
Géraldine Géraldine je vais vous dire
vous le savez on a énormément d'ennemis
et de gens qui nous veulent pas ne
croyez pas ce que vous avez dit là
beaucoup de gens vont s'en servir contre
nous et vous jouez vous serez également
perdants là-dessus c'est un mot et deux
mots qui sont extrêmement lourdes de
sens et qui vont être utilisés contre
nous alors que ce sont des mots qu'on
doit utiliser à bon escient là vous les
avez utilisé et je trouve que vous êtes
à côté de la plaque là-dessus et je vous
le dis il y a énormément de gens qui
vont l'utiliser contre nous contre
l'équipe de TPMP et qui peuvent mettre
en péril l'avenir de chacun d'entre vous
donc je vous le dis c'est compliqué et
c'est très grave de dire ça on peut pas
laisser dire ça c'est un antenne on a
tous dit que c'était très violent pour
la personne qui reçoit alors que c'est
pour le coup on a tous dit que c'était
pas le bon mot non mais non mais vous
l'avez dit mais Géraldine l'a pas dit
excusez-moi
je ne voulais absolument pas Judici
c'était juste un ressenti mais même sur
le plan moraldine aussi sur le plan
moral Géraldine je le retire il y a
aucun problème est-ce que je vous ai
déjà demandé de dire quelque chose alors
encore une fois enfin Siri c'est pas du
tout votre procès moi il y a tout va
bien c'est juste par rapport à la
séquence vous m'avez jamais demandé de
dire quelque chose j'ai une liberté
totale pour tout dans tout ce que je dis
donc là-dessus il y a il y a pas il y a
aucun problème en fait et je le dis tout
se passe bien entre Géraldine et moi on
s'éclate en loge avant le soir et
d'ailleurs je tenais à être là ce soir
et je vous remercie de m'avoir mis ce
soir autour de la table et donc il y a
aucun souci c'est juste que voilà je
vous dis que hier ça a été j'ai trouvé
que ça a été voilà je l'ai dit je vais
pas je vais pas le répéter parce que ça
suffit mais voilà alors est-ce que vous
voulez qu'on se fasse un câlin parce que
c'est ma mère qui demande
[Applaudissements]
parce que moi si j'y vais va dire que je
la harcèle
la plus connue
[Musique]
ouais Daniel je vais quand même
merci ma chérie et je voulais dire
quelque chose Géraldine et je le redis
je l'aime vraiment l'amour elle le sait
et c'est une de mes vrais amis dans
l'émission on fait beaucoup de choses et
voilà et donc je suis content de
t'embrasser ce soir voilà merci et
Daniel est rentre pas ce soir